T
IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
THEY HAVE WORKED OVERTIME TO THE
KNIFE, AND DEFLECT THE TRUTH.
BUT DEMOCRATS ARE CONSPIRING
WITH AN ARRAY OF ACTIVIST AND
BUSINESS LEADERS ON PLANS THAT
ARE ALREADY UNDERWAY.
MORE SIGNIFICANT THAN THAT OF A
SPACE OBSCENE $3.5 TRILLION GRAB
BAG THESE TWO UNOFFICIAL
POLICIES BOTH WEAKEN AND CHANGE
AMERICA FOREVER.
SIMPLY STATED, THIS ADULT AGENDA
INCLUDES MAINTAINING OPEN
BORDERS AND IS READY TO THE TURN
UP REPUBLIC ACTIVISTS THINK
AMERICA IS EVIL.
THAT WE ARE LIVING ON STOLEN
LAND.
AND THEY WANTED TO GET AS MANY
NEW DEMOCRATIC VOTERS IN HERE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND DENTIST WITH AN UNDERCLASS
WHO ALWAYS LOVED CHEAP LABOR.
TOP OF NEVER BENT OF IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT.
THEY PREFERRED THE FREE FLOW OF
GOODS AND SERVICES.
AND THEN CARE HOW IT AFFECTS ANY
OF THE LITTLE PEOPLE.
THEY NEVER HAVE.
AND AS FOR CHINA, THE AS FOR
TURN TO BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S
CONCERN FOR HUMAN RIGHTS,
TOTALLY OUT THE WINDOW.
THEY ARE HAPPY TO IGNORE APPROVE
THE PROVISIONS OF BASIC TO
DISSENT, WORSHIP, IF YOU'RE 12,
ET CETERA.
LONG AS THE CCP MAKES SOME, I
DUNNO, UNENFORCEABLE PLEDGE ON
CLIMATE CHANGE.
SAVE THE PLANET.
THAT DOES UYGHURS DIE.
AND WITH THESE TUBES IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, THERE IS NOT A TOP
INVESTMENT BANK OR MULTINATIONAL
IN THE WORLD THAT WOULD THINK OF
THE STEERING MANY AWAY FROM
CHINA.
WHY BOTHER?
THE SAD FACT IS, BY THE END OF
BIDEN'S TWO YEARS, FIRST TWO
YEARS IN OFFICE, AMERICA WILL BE
HOME TO SEVERAL MILLION MORE
MIGRANTS AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF REFUGEES.
AND AS WE OBSESS OVER OUR
DIVERSITY AND NEW CODE
MULTICULTURALISM, CHINA, "LIKELY
GROWN A LOT MORE POWERFUL THAN
AMERICA.
BOTH ECONOMICALLY AND
MILITARILY.
NOW, DON'T GET DECEIVED WHEN
EVERY NOW AND THEN, FOR
POLITICAL EXPEDIENCY SAKE THE
BUDGETING WILL TAKE ACTION THAT
SEEMS TO THAT RUN COUNTER TO
THEIR AGENDA LIKE DEPORTING SOME
PATIENTS.
THE NEW YORK TIMES EVEN WROTE
ABOUT IT.
BUT THAT IS ALL FOR SHOW.
>> HOW MANY HAVE BEEN RELEASED
IN THE U.S.?
>> THEY ARE LIT ON CONDITIONS
AND I THINK IT IS ABOUT 10,000
OR SO.
12,000.
>> HAVE BEEN RELEASED?
>> YES.
>> AND OF THE 5,000 THAT HESTON
MAY STILL BE PROCESSED?
>> WE WILL MAKE DETERMINATIONS
WHETHER THEY WILL BE RETURNED TO
HAITI.
PLACED ON OUR PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PUBLIC INTEREST AUTHORITIES.
>> ARE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A
TOTAL OF 12,000 OR COULD IT BE
EVEN HIGHER?
>> IT COULD BE EVEN HIGHER.
>> Laura: HE IS LYING WHEN HE
SAID IT COULD BE HIGHER.
BUT NO, MR. SECRETARY.
IT WILL BE HIGHER.
EXPONENTIALLY HIGHER.
BY DITCHING MOST ALL OF TRUMP
EFFECTIVE ENFORCEMENT TOOLS AT
THE BORDER, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SEND A MESSAGE TO
THE WORLD THAT OUR BORDER IS
DEFECTIVE OPEN.
NOW, LOCAL MEDIA IN SOUTH AND
CENTRAL AMERICA IS RUNNING ADS
HOCKING PASSAGE FOR ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO CROSS INTO AMERICA.
THE COST IS ANYWHERE FROM SEVEN
TO $10,000 NOW WHICH THEY CAN
PAY OFF IN INSTALLMENTS WHILE
THEY ARE WORKING HERE ILLEGALLY.
NOW, THESE ARE ECONOMIC
MIGRANTS.
BUT THEY ARE NOT LEGITIMATE
ASYLUM-SEEKERS.
BUT THERE IS LITERALLY THE ROGUE
DETERRENCE FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
IN FACT, IF THEY WANT THIS TO
CONTINUE.
NEW VOTERS AND CHEAP LABOR.
IT IS A WIN-WIN FOR DEMOCRATS.
>> WHY DON'T YOU BUILD, FORGIVE
ME, A WALL OR A FENCE TO STOP
THEM FROM WALKING?
IS THIS THE POLICY OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION?
>> WE DO NOT AGREE WITH THE
BUILDING OF THE WALL.
THE LAW PROVIDES THAT
INDIVIDUALS CAN TAKE THE CLAIM
FOR HUMANITARIAN REALLY.
THAT IS ACTUALLY ONE OF OUR
PROUDEST TRADITIONS.
>> Laura: CAN YOU BELIEVE THIS
GUY?
HE IS PROUD OF WHAT THEY ARE
DOING DOWN THERE ON THE BORDER.
IT IS DISGUSTING.
THEN YOU CAN, DHS SECRETARY
HUNDRED MAYORKAS HIMSELF IS KIND
OF A SMOOTH TALKING KRUPP TO
PRATT.
AND NOW HE OVERSEES THE BIGGER
SCAM AT THE BORDER.
>> SOME HAVE ARGUED AND IN THE
ACTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
LISTENING ENFORCEMENT.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS THE
WORDING THAT I WOULD USE.
WHAT I WOULD SAY THAT WE ARE
IMPLEMENT IN FAIRNESS AND
JUSTICE.
>> THE STATISTICS OF YOUR OWN
DEPARTMENT SHOW THAT THE FLOOD
OF PEOPLE COMING ILLEGALLY
ACROSS THE BORDER HAS GOTTEN
WORSE UNDER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
>> I WOULD NOT CALL IT A FLOOD.
>> Laura: IT IS NOT A FLOOD.
I WOULD NOT BRING IT THAT WAY.
CHINA'S WATCHING THESE CLOWNS
RUN AMERICA INTO THE GROUND
QUICKLY MUST BE THINKING TO HELP
HARD CAN IT BE TO THE ECLIPSE
AND DOMINATE ANOTHER COUNTRY
THAT BLOWS ITSELF SO MUCH THAT
IT DOES NOT EVEN THINK IT
DESERVES THE BORDER?
OR THAT U.S. CITIZENSHIP IS A
PRIVILEGE, NOT A RIGHT?
NO ONE CAN THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT WAS GOING TO LOSE --
OVER BIDEN'S POSTURE OVER THE
CCP.
THEY KNOW THE ALREADY CONTROLLED
BIDEN AND HIS FAMILY.
THEY HELPED MAKE HUNTER BIDEN
WHICH.
NOW THEY GET TO THE POINT WITH
JOHN KERRY.
TOP OF WHO JUST CAN'T STOP
SHARING TURN IT WITH PRAISE OVER
CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> IF TRY NOT MAKES A MOVE
AND -- SOMETHING POSITIVE AND
CONSTRUCTIVE, IT IS IMPORTANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO TRY TO SIT
DOWN AND UNDERSTAND EXACTLY
WHERE THE DIFFERENCES ARE AND
WHERE THEY MAY BE ABLE TO BE
BRIDGED.
>> Laura: HE SAID THAT
PRESIDENT XI TAKE THIS VERY
PERSONALLY LAST WEEK.
AND THANK HIM PERSONALLY.
IT IS SO HUMILIATING.
FORGET EVERYTHING THAT CHINA HAS
DONE TO PROVE ITSELF TO BE
UNTRUSTWORTHY.
TO CONCEAL THE ORIGINS OF
COVID-19, WE SHOULD HAVE CUT OFF
ALL ENGAGEMENT WITH THEM JUST AT
THAT POINT.
PART OF COURSE, CRUSHING
DISSENT, MAKING ACTIVISTS JUST
DISAPPEAR.
MEANT OF IT MATTERS TO THE
POLITICAL ELITE PIGMENT OF IT.
AND CERTAINLY NOT TO OUR TYCOONS
TO SEE OPPORTUNITY WHERE
BARBARITY EXISTS.
>> -- SPENT A LOT OF RESOURCES
AND EFFORTS TO APPLY DIGITAL
TECHNOLOGIES.
MAKING CHINA A GLOBAL LEADER.
INVESTMENT AND ALREADY -- IN
CHINA.
AND I SEND MY BEST WISHES.
>> Laura: THE FACT IS THESE
CEOs ARE RESPONDING TO THE
CLINICAL DOES POLITICAL CLIMATE.
THEY HAVE WATCHED AS OUR LEADERS
IN THE U.S. HAVE TEMPLATE THE
CHINA THREAT.
>> TURN IT IS GOING TO EAT OUR
LUNCH.
COME ON, MAN.
>> THERE'S NO U.S. STRATEGY TO
PUSH OUT AGAINST OR BE IN
CONFLICT WITH CHINA.
>> CHINA IS A RISING POWER.
THAT IS NOT TO SAY, HOWEVER,
THAT THEY ARE AN ENEMY.
>> THEY ARE NOT COMPETITION FOR
US.
>> Laura: BE THEIR OWN
GOVERNMENT -- NOT SEEM TO CARE
IF CHINA DOES THINGS LIKE
THREATEN TAIWAN WORK SLAUGHTER
THOUGHT LEADERS, DESTROYED ITS
FREEDOM IN HONG KONG, WHY SHOULD
ELON MUSK OR TIM COOKE OR THE
HEAD OF ORDINANCE ASK FOR THAT
MATTER PUT THE MOST RECENT
EXAMPLE OF BIDEN'S EMBARRASSING
TRIBULATION THE FORM OF A
PRISONER SWAP.
CHINA TOOK TWO BUSINESSMEN
PRISONER TO FORCE THE U.S. TO
DROP ITS EXTRADITION REQUEST OF
A WATERWAY EXECUTIVE IN CANADA.
THE CHIEF PROPAGANDIST INSISTED
THIS WAS ALL AN UNCANNY
COINCIDENCE.
>> IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE AND
BEEPS VERY CLEAR ABOUT THIS.
THERE IS NO LINK.
WE HAVE AN INDEPENDENT JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
WE CAN'T DETERMINE HOW DEPTH
CHINESE OR OTHERS MANAGE THEIR
BUSINESS.
IT IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
>> Laura: CHINA'S OWN
STATEMENT MEDIA HABITS HAVE BEEN
BRAGGING ABOUT THE PARTY'S
HANDLING OF THE MATTER.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CAN
SPIN THIS ANYWAY THEY WANT.
AND HE WILL.
BUT IN THE REAL BROKER EVERYONE
FROM BUSINESS EXECS TO FOREIGN
LEADERS TO DESPERATE MIGRANTS
ARE SEEING THE TRUTH.
AMERICA'S BORDERS ARE
UNDEFENDED.
AND IT IS RETURNING TO ITS
PRE-TRUMP POSTURE OF THE
SUBMISSION TO THE CHINA.
ONCE AGAIN, THE WORLD BELIEVES
THAT THE FUTURE WILL RISE OR
FALL IN BEIJING.
NOT WASHINGTON.